welcome back to new rock stars i'm
whitney van laningham and holy eggo
waffles y'all i'm so pumped for stranger
things season four the boys on bikes are
back baby and they've got one more d d
monster to fight before the series ends
vekna aka one of the most powerful
liches in fantasy lore but before we
take the weekend to marathon these very
long episodes i want to give you a quick
recap of the first three seasons cause
if you're anything like me you probably
need a little refresher on the upside
down let's get into it stranger things
introduces us to the best god damn
dungeons and dragons party in hawkins
indiana the group of four boys will
byers lucas sinclair dustin henderson
and mike wheeler's friendship is a love
letter to 80s kid gangs like the losers
club from it the goonies and even a
little e.t their love for d is actually
what helps them navigate the upside down
and its monsters as the party is able to
understand the horrors happening to them
through the lens of a fantasy campaign
if not for their nerd knowledge they'd
be demogorgon snacks by now will is
taken into the upside down an alternate
super terrifying dimension that exists
parallel to ours the party ends up
comparing it to the veil of shadows a
clouded part of the forgotten realms of
dnd that is full of undead shadows whose
only driving purposes are hunger and
hatred they're hangry guys so angry that
one of them emerges from the upside down
and attacks a girl named barb at a house
party in classic 80s fashion barb's
friend and mike's sister nancy wheeler
and her boyfriend steve the hair
harrington are upstairs doing some
[ __ ] so barb dies alone in a parallel
dimension because she doesn't know how
to shotgun a beer properly the gate to
the upside down was accidentally opened
by a girl named eleven with psionic
superpowers who was experimented on
during the government's mk ultra program
scientist dr brenner has been training
and forcing her to use a sensory
deprivation tank to allow her mind
passage into the parallel realm alone in
complete darkness eleven encounters our
very first demogorgon and in the
monster's defeat the gate between
dimensions is opened when will fails to
return home his mother joyce byers and
his brother jonathan contact the hawkins
chief of police jim hopper to help them
find him hopper is the quintessential
haggard 80s cop trope i mean the dude
brushes his teeth with beer in the
morning but he doesn't believe her when
the party realizes that no one in power
is looking for their friend they decide
to search for will themselves but
instead they find 11 who escaped from
hawken's lab the boys take her back to
mike's house and he lets her move into a
secret tent in his basement like she's
his sweet little e.t except instead of
reese's pieces elle's whole thing is
eggo waffles using a homemade sensory
deprivation tank courtesy of some
instructions from mr clark a middle
school science teacher 11 locates will
and slug barb
and joyce and hopper race to hawken's
lab to the location of the gate once
inside the upside down they find will
hooked up to all sorts of demogorgon
tentacles hopper manages to get him
breathing again and the three of them
escape together but back at hawkins
middle school the demogorgons aren't
finished with 11. using the last of her
powers she kills the monster dustin it
like thanos and sending herself back to
the upside down don't worry she escapes
and hopper feeds her waffles in the
woods however this nightmare still isn't
over because at the very end of the
season will coughs up what looks like a
sluggy baby demogorgon now let's hit
season two life seems pretty much back
to normal for some of these characters
joyce has a new boyfriend named bob
newby hopper is keeping eleven safe in
his home and the party adds another
member to their group max mayfield
others this season aren't so lucky
however mike is still pining after
losing eleven will is in therapy for his
upside down ptsd with a scientist named
dr owens and this conspiracy nut named
murray bauman is convinced that russians
have invaded hawkins and then there's
billy hargrove max's violent piece of
[ __ ] stepbrother also crops are dying in
fields all over hawkins and it's clearly
connected somehow to the upside down it
turns out that the gate has been
reopened deep in the earth beneath the
lap after bob has a heart to heart with
will encouraging him to face the monster
and his recurring nightmares head on he
decides to face it that night in his
sleep unfortunately he's possessed by an
even scarier creature called the mind
flayer in d d the mind player is a
powerful sadistic psionic creature who
believed all human life to be beneath
him and sought the destruction of the
forgotten realms in hawkins indiana its
hive mind wants to spread like a virus
and destroy every realm in every
universe it invades will's mind and body
and it's discovered that the mind flayer
likes it cold and hates the heat he has
a direct link to the upside down and can
think and feel everything that the
monster does he begins drawing creepy
shadowy vines and when joyce puts the
sketches together she and hopper realize
that the vines represent an opening to
the upside down located at the local
pumpkin patch mike convinces will to be
a spy and use his connection to the mind
flayer to keep the party posted on its
plans another new creature dubbed a
demidog makes its way to dustin who
adopts him feeds him nougat and names
him dartanian after the three musketeers
when it grows large enough it also
escapes to the upside down will is
hospitalized and they realize that the
only way to kill the vines is to get the
mind flare out of him first but after
burning the vines and therefore injuring
both will and the monster will is
possessed to betray the location of his
friends and family side quests there's
also a b-plot this season that comes to
a climax where eleven runs away and
joins the sid vicious x-men she's able
to track down her biological mother who
was tortured by mk ultra and fed lsd
during her pregnancy elle finds out that
her real name is jane and that there
were other kids just like her out there
who were also experimented on she finds
this punk rock magneto gang and hangs
out with them until she senses that
hopper has re-entered the upside down
also gotta squeeze in here real quick
that nancy and jonathan get drunk and
bang at marie bauman's house so she and
steve are done back at the hospital the
place is crawling with demidogs and poor
bob gets tackled and eaten by one which
although very tragic gives them some
time to escape back at home joyce nancy
and jonathan crank the heat up on will
and managed to force the shadow monster
out of him at the same time steve the
world's best babysitter and the kids
head down to the upside down to burn the
rest of the vines eleven returns and
manages to seal the gate at hawkins lab
with her powers and once again saves the
day as a thank you dr owensgifts11 a
real birth certificate with her old name
and her new dad's last name jane hopper
at the school snowball dance mike and
eleven finally dance together for the
first time after months of being apart
max and lucas also end up dating and
dustin practices steve's farrah fawcett
hairspray technique for the first time
but over at hawkins middle school the
shadow monster hovers overhead in the
night sky this time the gate is closed
but the monster is locked inside with us
in stranger things 3 it turns out that
murray bauman's conspiracies were right
all along the russians are now fully
taking over hawkins an homage to the red
scare of the 80s their scientists have
invented a machine that produces a blast
of energy strong enough to open the gate
to the upside down and is a lot more
deadly than eleven's powers another
scientist named alexi is tasked with
perfecting the technology in less than a
year and a hit man named gregory was
sent to hawkins as well to violently
maintain the secrecy of their operation
the russians have also invaded local
hawkins government making a deal with
mayor klein to buy him off in exchange
for the star court mall and several
other local properties the kids on the
other hand are having a [ __ ] in summer
break mike and eleven are making out all
the time much to daddy hopper chagrin
and max and lucas are breaking up and
getting back together like every other
week jonathan and nancy are dating now
and have internships at the local
newspaper dustin has spent the last
month at camp nowhere got a girlfriend
named susie and even built a ham radio
called cerebro capable of broadcasting
long distances steve is working at an
ice cream shop called scoops ahoy with a
girl named robin and lucas's little
sister erica is constantly shaking them
down for free samples even billy the
douchebag is having a fun summer he's
lifeguarding at the local pool and he
has plans to [ __ ] mike's mom will
however is feeling left behind he still
just wants to play d d but all of his
friends are into chicks and babes now
but when he suddenly gets the demogorgon
tingle at the back of his neck all hell
breaks loose and hawkins billy is
possessed by the mind flayer and dragged
to the source where the monster tasks
him with building an army of people to
aid in his infectious conquest now
billy's the one who likes it cold and he
begins sacrificing other hawkins
residents to the mind flayer rats
infected and possessed by the monster
are also running rampant through town
biting and zombifying people before
exploding into a puddle of rodengu the
gang starts investigating the mysterious
circumstances surrounding these events
nancy and jonathan take on their rats
while working at the paper joyce
realizes that the magnets keep falling
off of her fridge and seeks mr clark's
help in solving the insane clown posse's
deepest question magnets how the [ __ ] do
they work while trying to contact susie
dustin accidentally intercepts a russian
code and brings it to stephen robin to
help him crack it but when elle and max
are spying on the boys via the upside
down eleven accidentally runs into billy
in the darkness she realizes that billy
is possessed by the mind flayer but
although the party tries to smoke the
monster out of him by locking him in
asana billy breaks free and returns to
the source hopper and joyce find alexi
at one of the mayor's properties but
grigori attacks them they manage to
escape to murray bauman's safe house
with alexian tow and the latter
eventually betrays the scientists he
works for to help save hawkins
unfortunately alexi is killed at the
hands of grigori but at least he got to
try a red slurpee before he died even if
it wasn't jerry scoop's troop solves the
code leading them to an underground
secret bunker miles beneath the mall in
trying to escape they accidentally
stumble upon the new gate and the
machine that can open it all over
hawkins the fleet are exploding into
liquid meat and joining together to form
the body of a super gruesome monster at
the best of the mind flayer one of its
tentacles latches onto eleven depositing
a slug in her leg that begins to drain
her powers in the grossest scene i've
ever seen on television they managed to
dig it out but the damage is done and
elle no longer has her powers the gang
meets at the mall where scoops troop the
party jonathan and nancy and the adults
plan their attack alexi tells them how
to close the gate using two keys and a
passcode the number for planck's
constant scoops head off to cerebro so
that they can broadcast directions to
the gate to joyce hopper and murray
dustin is finally able to reach his
girlfriend susie but she insists that he
sing a duet to the neverending story
with her before she'll give him a number
to plank's constant
disease
[Music]
unfortunately
hopper is standing next to the machine
when joyce is forced to shut it down and
close the gate and is seemingly
disintegrated the upside down closes but
billy is trying to sacrifice eleven to
the mind flayer back at star court mall
she taps into his memories of his mother
from when he was a child and the love he
once had for his mom compels him to
sacrifice himself to the monster the
mind flayer dies when the gate is fully
closed three months later the buyers and
11 are moving away from hawkins and the
kids say a tearful goodbye ellen mike
promised to stay in touch and will says
he'll play d and d with the boys the
next time he's in town eleven finds a
last letter from hopper that he wrote to
her when she and mike were making out
nonstop in it he says that he loves her
and it's kind of the perfect send-off
for his character but over in russia
these comrades are still working with
demogorgons feeding them prisoners from
within their base and a teaser trailer
that came out in 2020 confirmed that yes
daddy hopper is still alive he's just
trapped into jail overseas with a bunch
of guys who want to destroy the world of
demogorgons then now you're all caught
up for season four follow me on
instagram and twitter whitneypuppy
follow new rockstars subscribe to new
rockstars for more analysis of
everything you love and thanks for
watching bye
[Music]
you